and the games the game should be
beginning and any moment now so here we
go it would be pretty bad if lessee
received the white pieces because I
prepared her for the black side of this
game so that's happened to all chess
players before though you know when
you're like go to the game you're like
oh I'm ready to play
the first move and then you're like
actually Danny you you black today ya
know I've uh I've done that I probably
shouldn't be eating ice from my iced
coffee but here we go we've got a d4
opening played so did you now you're the
coach you have to reveal the games
already going so it doesn't matter right
did you guys look at this or are you
already looking at a student who's on
her own we did look at this because I
mentioned that Knight c3 could be tricky
and just avoid Knight to b5
that's what I told her I was like watch
out Oh who's there Oh your arrows I was
like getting so excited do you remember
yes I'm so happy so happy love it
so again everybody Roberts highlighting
if the knight comes to b5 you clearly
have forking problems right there
so let's she played a6 Robert let's take
a listen into Leslie and see if she
described your advice interesting okay
this is okay this is fine I will do this
okay actually I'll just do mine oh wait
I need to move this out of the way so I
can do this okay she just screamed game
on she's ready so it's funny because for
the most part we love it good advice
[Music]
and there's no party hat the party ID is
you know the pond shade from b2 to d4
and you know d4 to f2 but you're not
getting the party hat with an eye on c3
yep
did she she she played Bishop e6 oh she
took your advice right you said play a6
stop the phrase next round yep and now
Bishop d6 she's doing perfectly she's
doing exactly what we looked at so I
wish we had Alexandra here to tell us
whether she described anything about
this to mate he'll I'm gonna guess at
this point Nate is probably a little
more on his own but still playing I
[Laughter]
don't think I want to I think I'm just
gonna move my queen here Castle says to
but personal so I told her not to take
on f4 so if she had taken on f4 white
would take back with the e pawn and have
a clamp on the position and so she
didn't do that
I'm just showing what you said we don't
take away her audio so good okay I still
have her audio now I'm gonna take that
off as well yeah that was perfect
because what I'd showed her often is
that why he's trying to go Knight to e5
and close down the position but never
take on e5 with your knight on c6
because after d4 takes d5 now you lose a
piece so she knows not to do that she's
not gonna do it she'll probably retreat
her Knight to d7 as I told her just to
create tension inside of the board this
is a some high-level chest I don't feel
like I ever had a coach hold my hand
better you guys are doing for them like
where was this when I was learning chess
wait you don't remember you know when I
stayed with you 20 18 and then we held
him okay different I remember a lot of
things about that trip okay look at this
Bishop g5 move so this is kind of
breaking principals chat when you've got
a
second move from a piece that's already
been developed and it also gives up
White's normal stranglehold so even with
Roberts advice for Foose Lee why
probably still she don't look to put a
piece on e5 this is a little bit of
losing the tension here what do you
think although it can be beneficial
because we didn't really look at these
Bishop g5 ideas and I hope she doesn't
play e5 because she realizes that 906
pinned yeah let's show that the whole
point
Robert Haile okay she doesn't but this
knifes in means that if you if he tried
to open the center Knight takes d5 would
be crushing on the spot that's a that's
a pinned pony and a promise so happy I'm
so happy she's playing so well this far
she's and she's playing fast one thing
about Foose Lee even though she lost
that game to voy voy she played very
quickly and confidently and if she
finishes this way and continues I mean
this is this is unlike some of the
commentary you and I have done for the
highest levels of chess and that I feel
like there's so much more like the Wii
that's a mystery like anything could
happen any moment it makes you that much
more nervous right you're like in a good
way I mean it's a total coin flip what's
gonna happen here I'm so far I'm just
happy she wanted the Castle queenside
she was saying she didn't really know
what to do in other situations and if
the position was too locked up she
wouldn't have a plan but she knows that
'if I've is an idea she should strive
for at some point wait the bishop just
go back to f4
yeah no neighs wasting time let's i nate
lee is a little rattled i think about
what to do let's take a listen in and
see what he's thinking
we got a full screen here
neat hill nicely how come how come I
never got a sexy tat I love her we focus
on different things I like the music you
like that you have a tattoo that's right
III the difference between other people
is I get other people to tance you
through three things defending what's he
doing okay
uh-oh uh-oh she went against your advice
Robert hmm no I think it's okay here she
realized that it's open for her the
position has become further into the
game and she went for it I don't love it
what no one's mad look one still
defended he stopped to trade now I know
why point is not defended coz of um so
interesting he's not taking back uh that
would be shocking if he doesn't just
take the bishop pawn is not defended he
asked a commission tintin tintin am I
the first person to mention that there's
a Christmas tree the background probably
not okay he lose appalling I feel like
this is you know home alone 25 years in
the future home alone when he never got
out right the parents never came back
you know he didn't have any parental
supervision so he became a full-time
streaming on Twitch he's self self
administered tattoos his name yeah
always envisioned that need he'll would
be the future name of a little
McAllister kid I just say how much I'm
enjoying my sippy cup was the last time
I'll shout out to it that's just an
obsession oh man alright so what do you
think Lucy's gonna do here the issue I
have with with taking is
it felt to me and again no criticism
into your sushi I was I felt like a lack
of plan like she didn't quite know what
to do and one of those positions were
probably she could have gone for a five
but it's hard when earlier e5 wasn't
good because the knight is pinned you
maybe don't realize you could do it now
and so now I think she's struggling a
little bit with a plan yeah she brought
the night in which is too soon because
look at how many white pieces are
attacking yet so she is going to lose a
pawn but on the flip side of things she
will be in space for the rest of her
pieces and I'd rather not be a pawn down
but if I can get some activity that
could be worth it later in the game yeah
it's a good point and especially at this
level and and you know when when players
are often relying on tactics right upon
while important is not it's not a it's
it's not a nail in the coffin so to
speak like it would be at Grandmaster
levels and so the fact that you she
could move this Bishop and open up the
rook maybe play Queen f6 and then
increase that pressure you have a rook a
queen at a knight hey Danny hey Robert
Oh Mike literally scared me inside the
yokes I am in Roberts mind he knows he
did you done with Alexandra Robert I
can't believe you taught her a 6 you
know how long we spent preparing maybe
5:00 this morning
like a good hour a good Robert all I did
was say hey if your opponent tries to
bring the knight to b5 in conjunction of
mission one f4 you should probably play
a6 to stop it before even happens that's
all
just because my coaching make sure that
I cover everything and can get a lot in
in an hour it doesn't mean that you'd be
upset with me
I can coach you how to coach yep I'm
coaching winners and natives gonna get a
dub and it's not gonna matter what I did
wrong Oh Alexandra how frustrated were
you when Robert gave you that text
message the text thread we shared
honestly so I don't know I actually
texted Robert before my stream was made
asking him for advice because I wanted
to see what was the trickiest line
against loosely
instead of him replying he's like oh I
was actually just about to teach foo
sleep how did it feel to be shut down so
quickly about you know coaching help Wow
Robert like very interesting language
you're using there what you think it
bothers me to be shut down no absolutely
not you know what I did I said that's
fine I'm gonna adapt and we're gonna
beat Robert and Foose Lee anyway well
honestly alligator right now you're
looking pretty good I mean this is this
is not the worst position for Nate right
up a pond and and very solid center so
this is awkward the tension here is real
chess you will tension my favorite kind
it's Jesse what I saw I saw that Chi you
had prepared Foose Lee with the castling
queenside and the Bishop d6 so I really
thought that if we got our Knight to b5
and traded she'd be out of her element
but you know what I also taught Nate you
know kind of the basics around this
opening he's just playing it so well
he's up a pond he's confident is looking
pretty good yeah he's honestly playing
this like a total boss so I have to give
you some credit here I know just throw
some shade your way but he's playing
extremely well and accurately this far
he's now up a pond and the position
isn't so clear because there's not a
plan for either side just yet but
Alexandre you clearly covered your bases
and then some with and you're also a
good coach with foosley so it's really
nice just because I say it doesn't mean
you just don't go back to being nice I
prefer you guys when there's chess you
will tension here let's keep the
argument going what happened ow Robert
Foose Lee's losing or cool wait just
yes she's pushing forward too much oh
man although you guys g14 you well
Alexandre I know you are very happy
right now but I hope later in this game
you've learned that you know firstly it
may not be nobody may not have gone her
way but she's a fighter and she's gonna
bounce back in this position um do you
wanna do you wanna make a bet Robert you
want to put your money where your mouths
at or is this just commentary trying to
prep her up here wow you were trying to
promote the gambling on a kid-friendly
stream right now who are you what
happened to you
we can know we can bet something nice
like a chess lesson or something a chess
young you know who might was a lot of
girls going around these days you're
gonna coach me do you enjoy being
friends with me Robert
Robert is not a coach that you should
always enlist when he you know cuz he
know Robert has very high expectations
maybe that's just of me maybe I'm just
maybe I'm the failure in his eyes maybe
he'll be nicer to you I don't know
that's true all right well I don't want
to stir up too much more drama I'll be
you know lurking and good luck with the
rest of the commentary you guys see ya I
see great by Foose Lee yeah she had a
good response to Robert I was critical
of e5 for a good reason but I think
she's recognizing the activity right I
wanted to play Bishop g4 instead of rook
e8 hitting the knight right and now it's
a weird position where her pieces are
very active but but even rook e8 is not
too bad
yeah and she took back an f6 so right
now position is down to pawns for her
but it doesn't quite feel like two pawns
because it's one pawn each side of the
board this is an extra d4 pawn and the
extra f2 pawn so of course it's good for
white you see the evaluation bar very
high for white but it's not so clear-cut
and I do want to say that under other
circumstances if Alexander said hey can
you just give me some help and go over
some chess with me I would say yes but
there's some bad blood between us right
now there's some animals up G but knew
that if she knew what Fuu see he had
looked at with Chi Yu that's kind of
like a you know a boat has live of team
boat is sort of they're scheming back
there so she they are sent to you to
teach Lucy something so then she can go
teach need hill and then one of the bets
that's not cool
come on now fair game I agree let's
let's take a listen into firstly a w
honesty her and Nate have both been
really getting into the commentary here
so let's let's let's see what Leslie is
thinking about her position
okay so so that's okay what am I going
that no that's a blender what do we will
like if I bring my rook out like here
you know or whatever my queen here I
feel like I can start doing the scissor
attack okay you know I'm gonna slowly
move my rook please this is this is a
thing we're like what players are
learning the game they put the piece on
the square because they think it'll help
them see better well I don't have to but
I feel like I should play it that's a
good move okay okay
Nate's winning the time game so that's
really bad so I'm gonna start making
really fast moves okay I'm a freak him
up don't do that don't do that what she
wants to do do not do that also
nothing's like blundered oh my god this
is okay that's fine
anything I'm protected right now okay
his queens are okay so yeah Nate is Nate
has gotten so much better
Jack terrible check would she hits those
pitch tones I almost think she has a
voice than synthesizer like her tone
changes so fast the pitch I'm gonna piss
my pants right now by the way takes h3
Jones did you know it's a very long-term
plan I don't know I have to move I'm
under time pressure I don't do well
under time pressure
let's just show everybody real quick
Bishop takes h3 was a very strong idea
because when the Queen moved to d2
undefended the night and this might have
actually turned the game around for her
so if and when we catch up with the
players will obviously have to show her
that idea yeah but now I'm worried that
d5 does happen for Nate and forking the
rook and the knight just has a
straightforward move here Wow Nate Hill
is playing well got to give him goodness
he really is playing an extremely solid
game where he's hasn't committed any
errors no we supposed rook e1 he missed
the fort but that's still a good move
yep yep again the fork everybody d5 was
Red Rover Red Rover send foosley right
over but he didn't see it but overall he
hasn't he has of an approach that's like
he's just he look at him Robert like
he's a very good student of the game
right for a beginning player he wants to
get better he's looking for like the
solid strategic approach so he's missing
some tactics but overall like he clearly
has like some big picture stuff in mine
and all of his plans okay but look at
Lucy go she put a bishop on e6 that
attacks the pawn a - yeah like maybe she
just trying to improve her pieces and I
have to say Dani well mate he'll play a
great game thus far does he know how to
win an endgame up just a pawn or two
right right in these players they think
Lucy might be thinking hey wait if I
were in this position up to pawns white
I don't know how to win so right yeah
it's not that easy for sure and by the
way Bishop takes h3 still possible
there's there's some craziness I mean
this this Queen is flying ei and that
might scare Leslie to keeping it where
it is but but again this is okay I've
loved g5 almost even more I know that
there's white has lots of good moves but
she's sticking with an attack of using
these pollens together which is
something she started a few moves ago
which she played h5 and your dress
I was just saying the current position
Nate can play Knight takes g5
because the Queen on f6 is needed to
protect the bishop on e6 but that's a
really hard move to find especially as
they're getting into time travel the
sacrifice a knight for a pond that
doesn't seem very logical yep and he's
worried about the attack I have his
stream open just in the background just
looking at see how the plays her
yeah well let's listen let's listen in
on him here in a minute we're in a
second here we'll yeah let's go for it
it's free there if I go over there wait
I have a fork I have a fork where she
has to O or she could be here yeah
interesting he saw it now but not the
ideal time work for a fork and she can
just take that use the fork need it I
was really five and with this defense
here it's about me this is more of a
spoons by the way when you go around she
actually has no bite so she could put
pressure on she'll get a knight back if
that's what she wants oh no if she wants
to get a knight back I'm still gonna get
game piece
because I couldn't handle anymore it was
that was tough we see firstly putting
her hands on her head she knew he knows
this is going downhill but you know if
she can speed up Robert this is gonna
come down to time in some ways right
this is this is one of the longest games
I've commentated on so far a lot of the
other games I feel work or blow outs to
a certain degree and she actually has
some attacking chances but she has to
realize how to do it right if she gets
her Knight to f4 and they try to open up
the kingside she has a chances here it's
okay metaphor for okay this is a chance
for a blunder everybody if that Bishop
goes to the wrong diagonal I say makes
them you say Forks make some force make
some for I've always wanted to do that I
do that someone actually finally played
it's because we work together it's
because do we come we finished each
other's do it okay we're listening in
let's listen to see if she points it
this I go here he goes here she doesn't
see it he has to take care okay it's
only three to play with dude I'm doing
we created that okay oh my god it's all
I'm the board
what's all the board of God
so he has two movies King I get a free
move dude dude she always thought it was
a chewed nothing like not even knowing
you played a fork seeing it and going
I'm a freaking genius oh my gosh
oh my god dudes too much oh we should
listen to her because she just said no
we're done this is key oh my god let's
see what neh oh my god poor Nate he is
falling apart
yeah or listening to him now it doesn't
even matter anymore nothing matters
anymore after watching this okay so you
can do it you can take a piece and chill
oh she can't take a piece in shush hey
she's doing it one though she took the
pawn yeah she can just take a clash oh
my don't blend your queen that's all
that you need to do here how much time
does she have 21 second she's only got
20 seconds that's the other week we've
lost track of the what's probably gonna
come to
- is is time and she made a good move
there yep and okay we're gonna have
Danny this is uh yeah this is it's gonna
be a ton of despite all the bananana s--
that we've seen bananana s-- I think
that's a thing this is gonna come down
to the clock oh my gosh I don't know if
I can handle this like it's it's already
been so near so well now she's not on
her you know anatoly karpov technique
you think oh it's one-sided the reason
why is alexandra botas coached Nate Hill
and I coach Ruthie so of course I have
yeah rooting interest here if if you
listen in you can hear the sound of
Alexandra beau tez screaming let's also
listen to Foose Lee I forgot about this
whole like make a queen thing I forgot
that that's part of the game
she doesn't know how to oh she's good
she's letting me get a queen don't let
me get a queen but look at the time
that's the best thing though she sped up
she's not gonna lose on the clock
anymore and she is two queens to one so
something that I've talked about with
her is that when you make a mistake it's
damn you may not be the end of the world
we think I'm just gonna eat this piece
okay well she said it really quickly
yeah and she's and she's trusting
herself down she's got made on the board
if she sees it like I said whatever
they're fullscreen I want to go like
golf commentator I think that Nate Hills
your queen D for check because she might
move her King
yeah but oh he should have okay now she
can do this I don't know if I should
just eat his Queen right here I feel
like I shouldn't I feel like I should
just do this move yeah check him eat
this piece she's world she's gone full
vacuum cleaner sucking it up scared
she's taking a ball Oh what I spoke too
soon closes cheers know how to close it
out
I watched her stream last night where
she was doing like Queen versus King end
games and to Brooks checkmates and she
has the ideas down okay
we gotta check it with Nate we got it we
got to go listening to Nate
he has life again
he got a free queen there oh my gosh I
can't believe it oh my gosh neither
could we
this game is turning you just that H
pawn too fast look at that email bar
white is slowly getting life huh oh my
gosh he sees it dude he's the best move
[Music]
oh my gosh but she's gonna pass pawn
back dude the world will never be the
same after this game oh my gosh this I
don't even know what to say there's no
point in even backing up to try to
figure out what happened just got game
gonna go on forever I gotta play ninja
tournament not tonight oh she's gotta
put this on a different a different
board and I think Nate will know how to
check me too
Danny then 15 minutes has meant to start
okay Alexandre boat says somewhere is
absolutely going ape bleep on camera for
her boy no he's bringing the king in
he's he think about Nate is he's so
strategically like he's clearly
literally done a little more work in
that regard if Nate wins unfortunately
there won't be an interview with him
because he has a fortnight tournament
right after this but he has checkmate in
one and I don't
okay he missed it there's still a chance
there's definitely a chance that's an
ape on Danny yeah this could be that
would be the most poetic justice right
if karma is real this game ends in a
draw
just bring the king up bring the game
help the pawn okay well she's doing it
there's a chance this is a draw so
you're saying there's a chance just just
a draw I think this is gonna be a draw
both bathing Danny
okay well it's theoretically everyone
the answer is it should still be winning
for white but I'm with Robert that at
this point it seems hey she's gonna push
the pawn okay this is actually still
winning for what everyone oh he's gonna
take it though when she gets a queen
he's gonna take it
put the King be one like him be more be
one okay she sees it it's a draw it's
gonna be a drug that keeps the king
there yeah you have to know the idea
goosed they take it had to bring the
king up we got to go did you wait he's
offering a draw he did yeah he offered a
jaw and she declined if I'm looking at
the chess table game chat she probably
didn't see that a drone was offer
she do we have to do it the rematch
she's trying to win still he but it's
not yet oh it's on me he didn't realize
it was his move yeah also he thinks like
if I did he would think this is a draw
is fascinating you know it's crazy that
move he just played it still winning for
white if he finds the right check okay
if King be one team to be three is
winning everybody because there's no way
for the black Queen to check my cat
strong he's offering a draw
yeah he offered a joshy declined it I
don't think she sees it there's no way
we can checkmate each other oh my god
okay okay now it's a draw oh he's be
enemy White's winning again at the
Millbrook trade Queens I'm gonna force a
draw oh my god wow did we deserve that
game I think we did did any you know
we're back given the double Oh
he just he just got off his own camera
let's we listen to what's going on with
Bruce Lee I didn't know that is how it
works actually I didn't know that if I
take your I don't know if it's King
versus King but that happens actually I
thought you just come teeter totter on
the board I didn't yeah we thought yeah
Bruce me was gonna be a clown for you
I hated everything about that I know I
had to Queens Oh what happens now are
they mad I think she knows she just
played the trainwreck game of the
tournament the chess broadcast is mad
okay all right we're gonna let her think
that we're mad isn't that funny that non
chess players think that chess players
get mad at them when they don't play
good moves like that's not a thing but
it's like they like and we're like oh my
god that's hilarious
she also gonna kind of phone calls he's
probably updating a friend
they're mad at me I don't know what I
did wrong no we're definitely not mad in
fact I'm proud of her for fighting back
to the very end there and that way I
teach her be battle like I mean we said
the only thing correct karmically in
this game would be a traje apparently
apparently it happened I I don't even
know what to say that was a wild game
one of the most excited given that the
last time you and i commentated together
it was for like the fidei candidates
tournament with like the world's most
elite chess players zero moves that made
the email bar do anything but teeny bit
right like this was like the most
topsy-turvy game we've ever commentated
on I mean that was a blast and also you
know there's time trouble there are
Queen blunders they're a good night for
since they were coming up with good
ideas and just putting everything
together but day that was phenomenal it
was it was crazy
I think the moment of the of the game
was was the moment of the match the
moment of the game was where this move
here right like I said we don't we don't
do games that have that kind of sliding
around this was so awesome the fact that
she didn't see it then saw it but after
the night got attacked
I think tried every other square with
the night before saying that the Queen
was hanging and it was like oh my god
wait a second that was absolutely
awesome I don't even know why I'm
reviewing this game
I think it's just cuz I I have to make
sure that I'm not dreaming this was
amazing it certainly was and you know
for Nate to be winning and then to lose
his Queen and then be like almost
hopelessly lost and then to come back
not only to get one Queen his H pawned
for the hero of this game daddy you got
Joe Queens with his h-bomb
oh man well then if you somehow just
missed it after missing a million and a
half ways to win in one or two moves
eventually may find super accurate
conversion to be totally winning and the
game ends in a draw I don't know what
we're supposed to do I am told we're
supposed to take a quick break before we
move on to the second part of the show
here so don't go anywhere the pod champs
continues here in just a few moments and
the world needed a break from slicker so
just in time we have Leslie joining us
Foose Lee first of all how do you feel
right now about that game that we just
saw hmm I would like to issue a formal
apology to all of my coaches yes I'm
sure that wasn't fun for you guys to
watch but okay is this funny thing is
that Nate was like the one person that I
felt was the most even with me I had no
clue how I was gonna turn out throughout
the whole tournament I was like very
nervous for this match in particular
because he was like the guy that we both
had three points like voyboy and then i
robbed and then it's us two in the
middle this is like the determining
factor for who goes into the winner's
bracket so I was like okay and she's
gotta beat Nate but he seems like pretty
good seem like or he blenders a lot
though but I blender a lot you know so I
felt like this and so the fact that the
match went like that can I reject your
apology on the grounds that you have
nothing to apologize for
I think you have really been learning a
lot and we just had a lesson before you
play it it was a very back-and-forth
game obviously it wasn't perfect but you
were really coming up with some good
ideas and trying your best so I don't
want you to apologize right how did you
guys feel when I lost those two queens
though well again we didn't we we had a
great time and like I said I agree
nothing to Apollo
for it was it was a very interesting
game from the perspective that it was
that it was very back and forth and
maybe you were right maybe you and they
were so even that the best you know car
Matic result is a draw it was crazy my
emotions during that game was like I'm
winning no I'm losing no one winning
know I'm losing no one really know I'm
really losing and then he offered a jaw
like four separate times I rejected I
rejected all of them I love that you
said that because your coach I said I
said Nate's offered a draw but Bruce Lee
declined it and Roberts like I don't
think she meant to decline the draw but
I'm so glad you said that you did mean
to decline to draw it was intentional
but only because I wasn't sure if it was
allowed to like if if this was not on
like a tournament I would have accepted
immediately but I didn't know the rules
about if we so I just wanted to play it
out but you're doing it for the fans
what you're saying exactly the fans just
cuz I was scared of playing another game
honestly to play so I'm just I I just
wanted to even if it was the loss just
make it quick I didn't lose but I didn't
actually don't know what the rules are
since since you are both tied everyone
looking at the standings can see Nate
hill and Foose Lee tied at four points a
piece
I'm gonna have to get word on that I
don't know what the rules are maybe we
get to have some sort of like what would
you say if Nate Hill wants to play
fortnight to decide who moves on now I
know I just don't that doesn't sound
fair but I think it's an accuracy thing
all right okay in which case I think I
had lower accuracy you did so you're
telling me I'm playing the consolation
back I'm saying that you're accurate
about the fact that you were not as
accurate as Nate so you're in the
consolation bracket oh oh man oh man oh
no no I'm happy I'm happy to be in the
consolation bracket actually do you know
who my next opponent opponent would be
we won't know until the games are done
but who do you want to play yeah
hmm who's in who's in the consolation
bracket so far so we have xqc slicker
Swifter Ludwig x/x chocolate bars
Yasuo but actually no we don't know if
it's if it's critical or or Yasuo
actually an in groobie so we don't know
yet I don't want to play critical I
think he's scary I think he did excuse e
that was brutal I mean I don't wanna
play Ludwig either he seems scary too
and and I don't yeah anyone else I don't
know anything else about the other
players skill wise um I play Janna and I
already lost to her so I would also not
want to play her Leslie what was step
one of the coaching advice I gave you
breathe there we go you can play well
against any of these people so no fear
no fear whatsoever
yes step two step two was also play a
six to stop 95 and you did that yeah I
did I uh I had a few tricks up my sleeve
to try to tease me yeah so oh good
no I was gonna say jokes aside you
actually played a fantastic start to the
game you followed your coach's advice he
was singing your praises here Robert he
was you played a great game overall I
think that one of the the moments of the
game for us was when you realized that
that 92 was actually a fork of the king
and queen this was definitely the best
moment the craziness oh my god no no I
didn't even know that's the thing I
played it to check his King and then he
moved his king and I was like his queen
that's insane I was trying to get him
credit oh I'm yeah you're genius you
knew it all along
accidental genie yeah yeah I didn't know
I can't take credit for it but it worked
so yeah I'm happy to play in the
consolation bracket and it's been a lot
of fun so far even though I came with an
absolute clown show
awesome well you leave the group stage
with an even record one win one loss and
now a draw so is that better than you
expected does that mean if I go into the
loser's bracket and I like draw with
someone there I'm like above like I get
like my point actually matters I believe
so yes oh look at you you're like okay
now I like this whole drawing thing but
yeah I thought that would be pretty cool
if it helped me in the loser's bracket
but yeah that was really fun and I I
hope that that was entertaining at least
to watch even though to play it was it
was awesome
honestly we would we could go through it
and turn it into a full a full lesson
you and your coach can do that later but
it really was good and jokes aside like
some of those games are actually the
most important for like your chess
growth because you can see in hindsight
you know obvious obvious areas to
improve on but I want us one thing
because we were listening in on you and
after the show you were you had a phone
call from someone or something and you
were worried that we were mad at us is
that something that you actually think a
chess player would get mad at you for
making mistakes is that a real thing no
it's more of like I there was points in
that game where like I had a huge
advantage I was up like 14 points and if
the game was in the bag and the fact
that I couldn't secure it and I know
that you guys are staring at that like
with these moves like that exactly how
to checkmate I'm just like teetering
around and then I throw up with that
lead I just knew that you guys mess it
your heart your blood pressure must have
been like that's a blackboard is true
that part is true it's a pretty good
representation what was happening with
us but they did it - no he did so Leslie
no this has been awesome
you've been you've been great and again
I can't wait to see what happens in the
consolation bracket you are gonna be one
of the you know Robert wasn't joking on
that you may be one of the best
performers of this first qualifying
bracket to not make it right so you're
uh you're suddenly a dark horse to win
the consolation bracket
so I'm coming for that price the
first-place prize
I got it I think you can do it you've
been improving just you know keep on
working I'll be glad to help you out
some more but you're really doing a
great job so keep your head up thank you
guys
appreciate it good luck and we'll see it
we'll see you for the next match okay